it's my pleasure to welcome to the
program today Astra Taylor who is an
author and documentary filmmaker she's
the director of the film what is
democracy and also author of the book
democracy may not exist but we'll miss
it when it's gone
great to talk to you I appreciate it hey
thanks for having me
so we've had conversations before about
what democracy is should be and could be
and one of the conversations that often
ends up happening between the audience
and me after those interviews are these
questions about is direct democracy
really the only type of democracy that
we should be going for and questions
like that and I find that a little bit
less interesting than something you're
dealing with which is the idea of is it
really democracy if there is dark money
if there is disproportionate power by
kleptocrats and corporations and
people's and people in positions of
power etc so just kind of start the
conversation has there ever been a
democracy and that could be a however we
choose to define it that was not in some
way influenced by those forces by which
many modern Western democracies are
influenced today it's an interesting
question I mean I've certainly been
involved in those debates you just laid
out right have you know is the only real
democracy direct then and not you know
not using structures of representation
and and so that influence is a bit of
the work I'm doing but I tried to ask a
different kind of question actually I
wanted to shift perspective and to to
look at democracy as a process as an
ongoing project in a kind of ideal that
we're reaching towards and one of the
consistent things that has thwarted
people in their democratic aspirations
has been the problem of economic
inequality and this goes all the way
back to ancient Greece so you know the
ancient Athenians didn't invent the
practice of democracy but they give us
the word which comes down to demos and
Kratos the people hold power or rule and
even in those
early days but you know they didn't have
a system that you could describe as
capitalism right they didn't have a
modern industrial economy like like we
do but nonetheless they were very
attuned to the fact that inequalities of
wealth would subvert democracy and in
fact in the Republic which is you know
the famous anti-democratic text by Plato
where he famously warns that democracy
devolves into tyranny he says very
clearly that the underlying problem is
that the divide between the rich and the
poor grows to the point where it breaks
the city into where the rich want to get
richer and so they put poor people in
Tibet and the poor can't live anymore
and so that this creates conflict and
leads to the rise of demagogues and you
know what we would consider populism in
today's terms so I think with the
problem of economic inequality of
something democracies have to wrestle
with and it creates all sorts of
problems for the way our political
system is structured today it in my book
in in in the framing I use what I say is
that there are these inherent tensions
and democracy there why democracy is
hard is because it involves
contradictory elements right so the
local and the global and the question of
who's in and who's out and the question
how to balance the needs of the present
with the future but intense inequality
economic inequality just makes those
tensions almost you know unbearable and
really makes exacerbates problems that
we have to negotiate no matter what yeah
I when I'm reminded of when I read Jared
Diamond's book Guns Germs and Steel and
in it he talks about I think he divides
people as potentially organizing in four
different ways going from I think it's
individual villages like groups of
families relatively small and maybe the
second one is tribes then fiefdom x' and
then more sort of like nation-states or
something closer to what we have today
and once you get to the fiefdom x' and
the nation-states it's really difficult
to imagine circumstances in which there
is not going to be some inequality
either be it economic or in terms of
cultural power which often comes from
disproportionate economic power now
there will be those who will hear us
talking and they'll say no you guys are
missing the reality that this is really
an economic
verse a ssin about socialism versus
capitalism and that you can have a
democracy that is far more equal if not
totally equal if you simply change your
system of government to one of socialism
but I actually think it's more
complicated than that I'm curious to
hear what you think about it
well you know in the preface to the book
and throughout I I you know invoke the
socialist project right because I think
socialism plays an incredibly powerful
role in advancing democracy as we know
it today I mean they were they pushed
for for suffrage for civil rights all
sorts of things I my my point is that
even in a system of economic
egalitarianism right so even if we were
able to close the gap between the rich
and the poor between owners and workers
right and and I personally have I have
an imagination that allows me to imagine
that I mean just like a hundred years
ago someone might say hey masters and
slaves that's just natural that's how it
always is you know now we say hey
there's makers and takers there's rich
and poor that's how it always is I
personally can imagine a world where
we've closed that gap but because we
know that we know some countries have
far less why hold degrees of inequality
than the United States today yeah you
know I think we could do a lot to to
lift people up and bring other people
down to a sane level we don't need a
world where we don't need a country
where three billionaires have as much
wealth as half of the population and so
the thing I'm trying to say is that the
democracy part is actually the
challenging bit because even in a world
we might call socialist in an economy
that is not capitalism as we know it
we'd still have to balance these factors
we'd stuff to figure out well when is
coercion legitimate or when can people
choose right
when do we marshal the expertise of that
only a few people have and when do we
you know harness public opinion right
when how do we balance the needs of
people who live today with people who
have not yet been born so the book and
in that I think when we look at things
that way we can say okay well democracy
is something that you know it's a
constant negotiation we have to
constantly reinvent it we have to
constantly think of new well who is the
people and how do they rule and so I
don't think that
you know socialism is this magic word
that would solve all of our problems my
attitude is that actually if we had a
more economically fair system if we had
a system where we finally had you know
political equality we were where we
understood women are equals of men and
people are equal to white people and you
know people without papers are equal to
people with papers if we finally had
that kind of equality that democracy
actually requires and the economic
equality to support that political
equality then we'd actually get to have
really really interesting democratic
debates because then we'd have to think
about things like well how do we have
contrada we have communities that have
say over the decisions that affect them
that have influence over the decisions
that affect their lives while also
taking into account the broader world
right how do we balance the needs of the
present and those who are not yet born
right that's the problem with climate
change so I think that democracy is
always going to be it's always going to
be difficult and but hopefully those
challenges will just get more
interesting yeah I in thinking about the
broader world I mean I hesitate to talk
about the the anytime you introduce the
term what is natural I mean remember the
around the gay marriage debate how
problematic that concept of what if what
is natural was but to think at least
hypothetically for a moment is the idea
of people being democratic a natural or
an unnatural idea when we think back to
humans like in a state of nature
hypothetically so when you think about
how humans interact at some of those
smaller scales in bands of a few
families is what might work or not work
they're not necessarily relatable or
translatable to populations of millions
or even hundreds of millions of people
as we now have in some of the larger
countries it's a saluted question given
the history of political philosophy
right yet always invoke the state of
nature this hypothetical situation where
you know people were either warring and
defensive in a Hobbesian sense or
actually living in peace without private
property and a Rousseau Ian sense right
yeah that's why I say I'm curious about
that I'm wondering if it's even the
right question to be I want to make a
relevant question I think it's you know
I think well it's interesting to me the
way you know political philosophy
promotes different
oh geez and and it comes and moments of
political rupture and and helps people
think through the problems of their day
I would frame things differently I mean
I think if you look at human history
there's all this contradictory evidence
right the history of democracy is you
know history of colonial conquest
imperialism I mean it's it's we live in
a nation that calls itself the land of
freedom that was founded on the ultimate
form of unfreedom slavery you know
people have made really terrible choices
in the in in the past but you know then
you can also look back at even
Democratic history and see that there
are all sorts of wonderful advances
right that people have had solidarity
they've stood up for each other that
actually this circle of inclusion is you
know expanding and if it's it's
imperfect and and and sometimes progress
goes into reverse so I I think the jury
you know is still out and that we
shouldn't extrapolate too much from sort
of you know some idea of a state of
nature
I liked it from the question actually to
go back to Rousseau in terms of what was
called the founding paradox and it says
founding paradox of political philosophy
and it's how do you make a democratic
people out of an undemocratic people and
you know if we don't naturally inclined
towards you know democracy especially in
a modern industrial you know global
system like the one we live in what we
have to do is we have to create the
conditions for us to be democratic
through culture through education
through organizations of solidarity we
have to nurture a democratic ethos and
that's our challenge I think as as part
of the many as part of regular you know
as part of a community of regular people
I think we also live in a system where
the powerful have exactly the opposite
agenda what they want to do is create an
undemocratic people out of a
democratically spirited people so that's
why you know famously in the late
sixties you know say mo Huntington and
others said there was a crisis of
democracy when when youth were revolting
and-and-and there was too much sort of
labor unrest but they were like oh no
there's you know for elites when there's
too much democracy it's a crisis they
want people to become more undemocratic
more complacent so you know I think
we're we're certainly standing in a
moment where there's a kind of
democratic inclusion that that people
not that long ago would have thought was
you know impossible right I mean people
said you know women were totally
incapable of a rational judgment
participation and needed to have their
husband speak for them so we don't know
what's possible and I think invoking
human nature is yeah often a not the
best way to go how can we interpret in
thinking about this issue what we now
know to be a reality that often
democracies can make the wrong choices
or at least uninformed choices or
sometimes ignorant choices or whatever
the case may be and whether we apply it
to the current administration or
whatever else it doesn't really matter
but conceptually I mean even going back
to some of the older teachings that you
cite in your work there is this problem
where oftentimes the the populace of the
more populous countries will have
uprisings or social social moves or
changes that lead to bad decisions being
made within the system how should we
think about that more broadly at a
political philosophy level yeah I mean I
think it's a risk that we have to take I
would never argue that democracy isn't
risky the demos can make bad choices but
I think just you know again just as we
might say okay there's all this evidence
that we can't trust the demos that they
are this unruly mob Plato warned of you
know that the democracy marginalizes the
wise and the virtuous which is what he
said in the Republic yes and we also
have to say the best ideas about
democracy came from people came from
people who were excluded right when
women said we should be included as
equal citizens they were outside the
community outside the political
community ideas about what democracy
could be have always come from the
margins from oppressing and Outsiders
and the other thing is that you know
we've we've tried technocracy that sort
of been what we've the system you know
that's some people talk about neoliberal
capitalism is one where the technocratic
but the experts in charge and and
they'll make decisions and you know
we've but we've had as a intense you
know escalation in terms of the
concentration of wealth we've had you
know systems emerge that are you know
too big to fail accept the fact they can
fail what we're facing is a climate
crisis that even though the science says
this is going to be devastating in fact
is devastating for for communities
climate change is happening now you know
we seem unable to stop it so you know
putting experts in charge you know and
dimin you know diminishing the power
with people hasn't worked either so
that's where I think we have to again
create structures where people can can
become more informed this is why
education is so central to to the
democratic project we also have to
create a media ecosystem that has
positive incentives before this book I
wrote a book called the people's
platform about the political economy of
the internet and how you know so much
the problem with it is that the
incentives are all towards clickbait and
fast churning content because you know
it's the the business model is
advertising is is is data collection
right so you know we're we're we're we
have to address these sort of underlying
economic arrangements that shape our
culture and in and you know distort our
democracy so we have to be holistic and
and have a complicated analysis but I
don't think the I don't think we can can
write off the people especially because
working-class people have been have been
again at the forefront of pushing for
things like public education pushing for
the right to be not just workers but
part of part of a philosophical public
right that that is is essential to
democracy yes and as my audience has
been hearing for the last month in
particular we really should do what we
can to separate the media landscape from
a dependence on ad revenue because it's
not I totally agree
the wrong incentives fundamentally
people have had this fight with you know
television we had to fight with radio
this is where we're not an unprecedented
territory right people said the media
landscape is being distorted by these
incentives and they pushed for Public
Television they pushed for controls on
advertising we need to do the same in
the digital sphere completely agree we
have been speaking with Astra Taylor who
is an author and documentary filmmaker
the dira she is the director of the film
what is democracy and author of the book
democracy may not exist but we'll miss
it when it's gone
so great to talk to you today hey thanks
for having me on